we've already thought about what a
definite integral means if i'm taking
the definite integral from a to b
of f of x
dx i can just view that as the area
below my function f
so if this is my y-axis this is my
x-axis and y is equal to f of x so
something like that y is equal to f of x
and if this is a
and if this is b
i could just
view
this expression as being equal to
this area
but what if my function was not above
the x-axis what if it was below the
x-axis so these are going to be
equivalent let's say let me just draw
that scenario so let me draw a scenario
where
it's my x-axis that is my y-axis
and let's say
i have
let's say i have a function that looks
like that so that is y is equal to g of
x
and let's say
that this right over here is a
and this right over here is b
and let's say that this area right over
here is equal to
5.
well if i were to ask you what is the
definite integral from
a to b of g of x dx what do you think it
is going to be
well you might be tempted to say hey
well it's just the area again between my
curve and the x-axis you might you might
be tempted to say hey this is just going
to be equal to 5
but you have to be very careful because
if you're looking at the area above your
curve and below your x-axis versus below
your curve and above the x-axis this
definite integral is actually going to
be the negative
of the area
now we'll see later on why this will
work out nicely with a whole set of
integration properties but if you want
to get some intuition for it let's just
think about velocity versus time graphs
so
if i in my horizontal axis that is time
my vertical axis this is velocity and
velocity is going to be measured in
meters per second time is going to be
measured in seconds
time is measured in seconds and actually
i'm going to do two scenarios here
so let's say that i have a first
velocity time graph let's just call it v
one of t which is equal to three and it
would be three meters per second so one
two three
so it would
look like that
that is v 1 of t
and if i were to look at the definite
integral going from time equals 1 to
time equals 5 of v sub 1 of t
dt what would this be equal to
well here my function is above my t axis
so i'll just go from 1
to
5 which will be around there and i could
just think about the area here and this
area is pretty easy to calculate it's
going to be 3 meters per second times 4
seconds that's my change in time and so
this is going to be 12 meters and so
this is going to be equal to 12.
and one way to conceptualize this is
this gives us our change in position
if my velocity is 3 meters per second
and since it's positive you can
conceptualize that as it's going to the
right at 3 meters per second what is my
change of in position well i would have
gone 12 meters to the right and you
don't need calculus to figure that out 3
meters per second times 4 seconds would
be 12 meters
but what if it were the other way around
what if i had another velocity function
let's call that v sub 2 of t that is
equal to
negative 2
meters per second and it's just a
constant negative 2 meters per second so
this is
v sub 2 of t right over here
what would or what should the definite
integral from 1 to 5 of v sub 2 of t
be dt be equal to
well it should be equal to my change in
position but if my velocity is negative
that means i'm moving to the left that
means my change in position should be to
the left as opposed to to the right
and so we can just look at this area
right over here when if you just look at
as the rectangle is going to be 2 times
4 which is equal to 8 but you have to be
very careful since it is below
my horizontal axis and above my function
this is going to be negative
and this should make a lot of sense if
i'm going 2 meters per second to the
left for four seconds or another way to
think about it if i'm going negative two
meters per second for four seconds then
my change in position is going to be
negative eight meters i would have moved
eight meters to the left if we say the
convention is negative means to the left
so the big takeaway is if it's below
your function and above the horizontal
axis the definite integral and if your a
is less than b then your definite
integral is going to be positive if your
a is less than b but your function over
that interval is below the horizontal
axis then your definite integral is
going to be negative and in the future
we'll also look at definite integrals
that are a mix of both but that's a
little bit more complicated